(group chanting)
(foreign language)
- [Host] After President
Vladimir Putin mobilized
ordinary Russians to fight
in UKRAINE in September,
large protests broke out.
Families more in conscripts
who died on the front lines
and hundreds of thousands of
RUSSIAN men fled the country.
But these aren't the images that Russians
are seeing on state media.
(foreign language)
National television showed
the president firing a rifle
and inspecting RESERVIST
who looked all set to fight
and citizens say on air,
they're fully prepared for combat.
(foreign language)
As Putin faces a backlash
against the MOBILIZATION,
here's how the state PROPAGANDA
machine has stepped in
to try to reassure the population.
(foreign language)
When the MOBILIZATION was
announced, STATE TV reported
that men were flocking to
recruitment centers out
of patriotism, and it
showed smiling families
sending their loved ones to war.
The RUSSIAN army said it was
drafting ordinary citizens
to help hold the front lines in UKRAINE
and anchors said the population responded
with a wave of support.
(foreign language)
Those reports came
as recruitment centers were
being targeted by a series
of attacks and polls showed
growing anxiety among Russians.
According to an independent
pollster, the number
of Russians who think that the
campaigning UKRAINE is going
as planned dropped to 53% in
September from 73% in May.
Days after announcing the
MOBILIZATION, Putin admitted
that the way the DRAFT was
managed raised many questions.
(foreign language)
But in October, the KREMLIN
start to face criticism
as new recruits started on the front lines
just days after being summoned.
Some families say they
were poorly trained.
(foreign language)
New recruits also complained
about equipment shortages
saying they had to buy things such
as flashlights or sleeping bags themselves
(foreign language)
So news reports start
to regularly cover those
themes mobilize men going
through battle drills
dressed in mint condition uniforms
and equipped with all the
gear needed for combat,
helmets, bulletproof
vests, and sleeping bags.
(foreign language)
And the president himself went on camera
and gave a word of encouragement
to the new draftees.
(bomb exploding)
(foreign language)
It's hard to tell how effective
the state PROPAGANDA is.
According to Border Authorities
in Europe and other countries,
more than 300,000 Russians
have left the territory
since late September.
Many say they fled to
avoid being sent to war.
Still, many Russians express
strong support for the INVASION
of UKRAINE and are not
averse to the MOBILIZATION.
(foreign language)
The KREMLIN said that even
though there were problems
with the MOBILIZATION
the situation shouldn't be generalized.
According to Putin, reservists can be sent
to the front lines after
10 to 25 days of training.
In late October, handout footage
from the RUSSIAN
government showed Russia's
Minister of Defense telling
Putin that the MOBILIZATION
was successfully concluding
with some 300,000 men drafted.
However, many Russians
say they are skeptical.
The President didn't
sign an official decree
to end the DRAFT saying
it wasn't necessary.
This has fueled concerns
that the MOBILIZATION
could resume at any moment
as RUSSIA continues to
suffer setbacks in UKRAINE.
(upbeat music)